the market cannot bully the American
people they're going to eventually get
caught but the government can bully
American people that's exactly what
they're doing today they're bullying
American people and so although you're
right we're a person on the free market
side because they're getting paid for
the work that they're doing
you know they may be like well if you
give me 500 000 I'll give you the
information if you give me a million
dollars but we know a lot of government
agency people have done that as well and
you know sold their sold to I can tell
you stories there's plenty of Articles
of different names you know them I know
them we've read about them so but my my
bigger concern is free enterprise cannot
take my freedoms away but the the
government can't take my freedoms away
and Bully me and uh a lot of times what
they do is they use
you know like Andrew Tate this guy never
met him never talked to him we're
probably going to do podcasts together
eventually but uh he said some stuff I
agree with and I love the fact that he's
pushing the envelope all of a sudden hey
let's silence this guy okay why because
uh he's got a case going on with uh
women and all this other stuff okay
there is criminal activities that you
have to you know be held accountable for
and then there is Banning because he's
saying some stuff you disagree with on
the criminal side if I break the law yes
I have to go to court and if I'm doing
time I'm doing time big difference I
don't know what he's done if he's done
crime hey that's the level of
accountability but Banning somebody for
things you disagree with O.J Simpson is
on Twitter
is on Twitter Putin who just killed a
bunch of people he's on Twitter he ain't
banned how come they're not banned
you're afraid of what this guy's going
to be doing so that's the part where I
wonder if Government gets involved in
saying that guy's been a little too loud
shut this guy up and I I free market can
bully by saying and we don't want your
customer it's simple Facebook can say
that Twitter can say that Instagram
can't say that but are they saying it
because they're saying it like this
whole story going into Facebook where
you know he sits with uh Rogan uh uh uh
yeah Zuck sits with Rogan and they go
through a bunch of different stories and
uh you know here's a story from Fox
Business FBI responds to Zuckerberg's
claim on Rogan that Facebook limited
Hunter Biden's story uh after agency's
warning and appearance by Mark
Zuckerberg on Joe Rogan podcast last
week still controversy after metal Co
admitted that Facebook limited the
bombshell Hunter Biden laptop story
ahead of the 2020 election because the
FBI had warned about Russian propaganda
after the release of the episode on
Thursday the FBI said it routinely
notifies U.S private sector entities
including social media providers of
Potential Threat information so that
they can decide how to better defend
against threats the agency said it has
provided companies with foreign threat
indicators to help them protect their
platforms and customers from abuse by
Foreign malign influencer influence
actors okay
you read this
I can take this in a couple different
ways one way I take this is Zuck did
this intentionally
because he's like I'm so sick of you
guys targeting me leave me alone okay I
have two customers the left to right I
have to kind of deal with both of you
guys and both of you guys hate the other
side I get it but let me do my job so
maybe he said this publicly
intentionally to get under FBI's skin
and kind of have them be exposed a
little bit maybe ten percent I believe
it was intentional
did he do it accidentally he's too smart
to do it accidentally like was Joe
really cornering him and pressuring him
you better tell me or else and you know
here's no it's just a basic conversation
the way he came out
could it be accidental but when somebody
says something like this
this just keeps hurting more and more
and more so the FBI bullied the American
people through cornering a free
enterprise company that made them
silence because they didn't have the
Intel that the FBI claimed they had and
they couldn't verify it through private
agency that's a competitor to FBI that
they had to kind of take that position
and because of that we have the greatest
motivational speaker of all time as our
President Joe Biden right so it's kind
of like a very weird situation that
takes place here
yeah so what you're I think that there's
a couple things that we want to keep in
mind we want to keep in mind the context
of the situation so if you recall 2016.
first of all let's be let's be very
honest with each other
Russian meddling in the U.S elections
did not start in 2016.
every election cycle ever has had people
trying to meddle in the election what
happened is that in 2016 social media
got caught
that's what happened in 16. before then
we could all kind of pretend it wasn't
there it's like the it's like that Uncle
in our family that we don't want to talk
about because they're kind of maybe
they're a criminal or maybe they went to
jail or who knows what they did but we
don't really we don't want to we don't
want to be the one who calls the police
and turns the uncle in but we also don't
want to be the person who admits that we
know the uncle or the uncle's in our
family right that's exactly what happens
with Espionage almost all the time
people don't want to admit that it's
there but it's happening all the time
it's that ugly wart on your butt you
don't want anybody to know about right
what happened in 16 is everybody saw the
ward
Espionage became a household word
influence campaigns covert influence
became household conversation in 2020
everyone was expecting it to happen
again Trump was like back back in the
race Russia was still involved all the
16 investigations came to fruition in 18
and you had CIA basically telling us
that they couldn't trust the president
and the president saying that they
didn't trust CIA and it was a disaster
it was a total mess the social media
companies did not want to get stuck in
the middle of being accused in the
future of being willing uh voices for
propaganda from Russian meddling or
Chinese meddling or Iranian meddling all
of which happened Saudi meddling happens
right nobody wants to nobody wants to be
on the X for that so the more cautious
approach is to just shut it down if FBI
calls you and says hey this is Russian
meddling we think this is Russian
meddling what does what does Zuck have
to lose by being overly cautious and
just doing what they tell them to do to
a certain extent you're right he's
saying just leave me alone guys let me
do what I do I'm not a political
mouthpiece I'm just a social media
channel
but I'm also a business owner and the
Practical solution here is if the FBI
tells me that I might be being abused by
the Russians I don't want the Russians
to abuse my platform so I'm just going
to shut it down
two years later we have the benefit of
time now now we can look back and look
at all the information he had limited
information in a short period of time I
actually am really proud of Zuckerberg
for saying it publicly like hey I agree
I had to shut it down guys it doesn't
mean that FBI is bullying me it means I
took the more conservative decision and
maybe that was the wrong decision but by
the way that's publicly standing up to
FBI correct and then that's he had we
all as American citizens we have the
right to stand up to our own government
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]